who is the most powerful dragon in TV
and film will treat all footage of
dragons like it's real video evidence of
their abilities make a physicist study
it to extract hard numbers on their
speed and strength then simulate a
dragon worthy challenge to see which one
comes out on top this is power levels we
polled what we think are the three
strongest dragons from the three most
popular fantasy franchises drogon from
Game of Thrones the hungarian horntail
from harry potter and Smaug from The
Hobbit movies for their challenge will
make them sprint the distance from
Hobbiton to mount dill 1030 miles as the
dragon flies then use their breath to
melt a wall of ice that's 30 feet thick
700 feet high and 300 miles long the
time it takes them to finish these tasks
should give us a baseline for cross
franchise comparison let's start by
making these dragons drag race all three
take off from Hobbiton at their top
speed to get that we picked moments when
they were pushing themselves to their
absolute limits flakes mugs assault on
Lake town in the third best Hobbit movie
by analysing the scene we can take
objects in the background we know the
approximate size of like a house with
Luke Evans barred on the roof and count
how many of these houses smiled flies
over in a given amount of time distance
over time equals speed equals math
equals smog takes about four hours to
get to our wall it would take 16 hours
for the hungarian horntail going off the
scene where he chases Harry and Goblet
of Fire and six hours for drogon from
the scene where he absolutely wrecks the
Lannisters in the spoils of war episode
of Thrones god I loved that one once
they've arrived at the wall it's time to
melt it like my heart when Jon Snow
pouts which is always we can easily
guesstimate how hot each Dragons flame
is by analysing their colour take the
scene where drogon melts the Lannister
armies leaving Highgarden
rather the flame the colder it is the
whiter and bluer the hotter by
converting the RGB value of dragons
flames to a temperature we can
approximate his breath at 7500 degrees
Fahrenheit by applying the same process
to smile he measures 11,000 and horntail
fox in at an even 7k but temperature
isn't really the factor that'll melt
this thing down it's the amount of
energy they put out which is the rate at
which they can deliver the heat we're
gonna assume that dragon breath is
mechanically similar to a welders
blowtorch and that all three dragons are
running off the same fuel source because
give us a break okay if we control for
that we can look at the volume of fuel
expelled over time to determine how fast
energy is being transferred to the wall
then figure out the size of their flames
the same way we figured out their top
speed by comparing it to objects we can
reasonably know the sizes from that we
can calculate the rate of energy
transfer and get their total times smog
would take 735 years to finish melting
the wall
drogon would take 1700 and the horntail
would take 17,000 holy crap this
challenge is impossible isn't it okay
how about this let's shrink our ice wall
down until it's 30 by 30 by 10 feet like
a really cold airport Starbucks much
better now it takes mild a more
manageable 5.7 hours
drogon 10 and the horntail 56 so now if
we add up their times smog appears to be
the most powerful of them all Congrats
smoke you'd also win a competition for
the richest dragon largest dragon and
the most soothing baritone
[Music]
drogon comes in second and the horntail
places dead last
but don't despair fodder fans your
franchise still has the most powerful
talking hat and no one can ever take
that away from you of course in reality
this challenge would get a bit more
complicated you could raise the very
valid point that dragons get tired so
maybe we should sub in Viserion for
drogon never slows down to rest
the problem with visi is that when we
measured the heat of his flame it came
out hotter than most of the visible
stars in the universe yet the entire
north isn't vaporized the second he
opens his mouth so something fishy is
going on there we suspect magic you
could even be a stickler and say dragons
are so strong-willed you'd have to line
the wall with bars of gold to even get
smoke to bother with it which would set
you back a cool thirteen billion but I
like to think you'd do it for half that
the point is you can have all kinds of
pedantic fun with who should be ranking
the highest but if you're going off
their raw speed and power numbers the
choice is clear
their smile than everyone else sorry but
Dabba doesn't care about your favourites
but we care about you
so let us know which characters you'd
like to see compete in the next episode
of power levels and we'll keep putting
sci-fi and fantasy to the test of
reality
[Music]
you